how is it opening for Jordan Peterson
what kind of crowd is that did you and
you're not you're not doing you're not
doing stay are you doing open it with
stand-up or it was mostly crowd work and
I like drop some funny references about
him and he sounds like Kermit the Frog
and he talks about lobsters a lot like a
lot of like insider Jordans yeah but it
was incredible I mean we did a year and
a half together a hundred and twenty
shows something like 20 countries I went
to all these places not only in America
but all over the world that I had never
been to Finland Sweden
you know never been to Ireland before
the crowds when he goes to Finland well
the Sweden shows were incredible because
Sweden has a major political correctness
problem because there they really view
conformity as good in Sweden so it's
always very funny when all the AOC is
and Bernie they're like we should be
more like Sweden it's like well actually
what you're saying is we should be like
this absurdly tiny homogeneous country
that now in the last couple years
they've led in immigrants and now they
have all sorts of problems so they don't
even know what they're talking about but
Sweden the show sold out literally in a
minute so we added a second one so we
left Sweden came I think we went to
Finland and came back the shows mostly
were in theaters that were like probably
two to six thousand I think six was the
biggest big boy every single show was
sold out I think maybe except for one we
I think the show in Dallas they put us
in like they put us in the Toyota Center
have you ever been there it's like it's
not it's not a theater it's basically
like a giant convention center so you
can't sell it out because he's just
following he changed people's lives yeah
I saw things that you cannot imagine I'm
talking people off drugs people yeah
well every addiction name and addiction
he solved people's addictions people
I'll give you one we we finished the
show in Dublin and you know when you
walk out the artists entrance because
you know he doesn't want to get mobbed
right out in front and he's had a day I
mean we got that we got to town that
morning signing all the autographs all
the meet and greets taking all the
pictures the press hits an hour and a
half lecture that was different every
night he's beat it's like 1:00 a.m. we
walk out the side and we see these two
guys in the alleyway and ones like about
60 the other ones maybe 25 or so and
they're both crying and they're hugging
they kind of run up to us and it turns
out that it's a father and son who had
had a falling out five years before had
not seen each other in five years they
both bought the block
then both ended up at the show saw each
other come on and made amends that night
tell us the story now Jordan starts
crying his wife with it was with us she
starts crying the tour manager John
starts crying I start crying I mean it
was like like you like you can't make
something more real UK and when they
make the movie about Jordan and when
they remake that scene it will not be as
powerful as it was it was like and I saw
that so I can't say anything that's not
public I spoke to him last week and I
saw him a few months ago he's getting
better
um he you know they try to frame it like
he's like it was like a drug addict and
all this stuff he was very open about it
his wife in the midst of his success in
the midst of like this unprecedented
worldwide like crazy success his wife
was diagnosed with terminal cancer I was
out to lunch with him you know in think
we were in Des Moines when he got the
call and and we continued he continued
and he was very open about being on a
very small amount of klonopin which is
an anti-anxiety drug and then as things
got worse with her and she wasn't able
to tour with us he upped the amount and
he regrets it and he did and and then
what happens with some of these
anti-anxiety ziz it actually has they
call it a rubberband reaction or
something where you actually end up
instead of being you know you the idea
is that if you take more oh you're gonna
have less anxiety but eventually it just
actually does the complete reverse but
he's getting better he's getting better
he's his books coming out I think and
they're just thoughts on us he's not
here but what's his thoughts on kovaydin
office I've only the only thing I can
say is that what Jordan I think wants to
fight in this world more than anything
else is authoritarian government he that
is his main thing that he wants to stop
he wants people to be free you want it's
just that Lee said at the beginning it's
amazing how authoritarian yeah these
quote-unquote liberal governments are
yeah it's amazing how authoritarian
someone like Gavin Newsom and and Eric
Garcetti knows right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] desert city